hey everyone i'm ranita young with quick
take and today we found out that one of
the officers
in the brianna taylor case was indicted
but no charges were directly linked
to her killing and right now we have
brianna baker she's the founder of
justice for black girls brianna thank
you so much for joining us today
of course of course it's an honor to be
here thank you all for
curating the space to center um black
women and girls during this time
absolutely now why don't we just start
out with your reaction what's your
reaction
to uh the the the movement that's
happened overall
first right right in the words of fannie
lou hamer i'm sick and tired of being
sick and tired right i'm heartbroken i'm
i'm overwhelmed with emotion um not just
at the fact that um brianna taylor still
has not received justice but about the
fact that i knew
this was going to be the case before i
even opened the headline
um history told me what the verdict
would be
history has always told me that black
women
experience second class citizenship in
america right and that there is nothing
new
about the ways in which our bodies are
less valuable than our aesthetic and so
here in this moment there's an urgency
around
rallying and centering black women and
girls and so again thank you all for
being here
overwhelmed emotional but ready to move
forward and to demand justice
you have a specific reaction to the
indictment itself do you think this is
actually justice
yeah um in no way shape or form is this
justice
um this woman laid dead
and what received more justice was the
property next door to her
in this capacity a mother has lost her
daughter
a 20 year old girl has lost her big
sister
right and a boyfriend has lost his
friend his love or his partner
there is nothing just about a woman
being killed in her sleep
as a result of state violence there is
nothing just
about the settlement there is nothing
just about a world
that continuously shows black women and
girls that they don't matter black women
and girls are not disposable
right this justice for us looks like the
right to live
justice for us looks like black woman
healing it looks like liberation it
looks like joy
it's not just talking about black women
and girls after we die right it's about
celebrating our lives and the way that
we live
and so until brianna taylor because
brianna taylor cannot live
this is not justice and because her
killers are able to walk away with
impunity
um this is absolutely not justice hmm
okay okay and just as you alluded to
this is unfortunately nothing new
um unfortunately there have been several
black women ahead of brianna taylor and
and may just as well be some after her
um how do you process it's the fact that
uh
america how america relates to black
women and there's been a problem
in a lot of different ways at how
america relates to black women and girls
how do you process
this being a black woman um
being a black woman is about cleaning up
a mess that you didn't create
consistently it's about being required
to not just be twice as good but be four
times as good because of misogynoir and
intersectionality right
kimberly crenshaw and moya bailey do
excellent jobs of theorizing the
experiences of black womanhood
when you think about intersectionality
you think about the ways in which
different parts of your identity um
influence the way in which you
experience the world right so
i don't just experience racism as a
black person i experience sexism
as a black woman right and because of
misogyno i'm thinking about the ways
patriarchy and internalized sexism
impacts my particular experience as a
black woman and so there's
always a reconciliation about what it
means to be not only black
but to be woman and for folks that are
black women and queer or black women
queer and muslim or trans or gender
non-conforming
the list goes on about the ways in which
the world asks you to other yourself
or silence parts of yourself or fragment
parts of yourself
and so this is not just about black
women but all
folks who have to identify as other
right all folks who whose experiences
are not central
to america's all folks who have to
hyphenate their american experience as
if
them themselves are not american
thank you for sharing that and you know
what else um i think it's
interesting that this starts
when you're a little black girl
absolutely you talked about
some of the microaggressions and
criminalizing black girl
i've read studies on how little black
children
are actually treated more like adults
more like adults from grade school how
do you feel about that how what do you
make of that and what do you think where
do you think we stand right now with
that
yeah yeah it's it's a current problem
right and again it starts as girls are
young um studies show that
through adultification bias that black
girls um particularly between the ages
of 5 and 14
are seen as less innocent less childlike
less knitting of protection less living
of nurturing there are grown folks who
are looking at
five-year-old black girls as adults um
that is our
problem that is something that we need
to unpack and because of this
black girls are suspended um six times
more than their white counterparts
they're expelled
53 times more than their white
counterparts they are kicked out of
school they're funneled out of schools
and into criminal legal systems
and not for um explicit forms of
misbehavior but because of subjective
forms of misbehavior like talking back
um there are girls that have been
sentenced to um incarceration from
school for
throwing a piece of cake on the floor
not picking it up to the satisfaction of
the officer right these are
the real life experiences of black women
and girls and again it starts
with childhood and so we have to do the
work to unpack we have to do the
work of unlearning so that we can truly
see black women and girls as black women
and girls
as women and girls and as human
what can non-black women non-black girls
do very practically
to help stop this some of those issues
that start
when you're a little black girl uh what
what can everyone
else do can they simply notice it what
what can they do
sure and so the first thing that you
have to do is teach yourself right
because it's super difficult to change
without knowledge of what needs to be
changed so the first thing i would
suggest is that you pick up either
push-up by monique morris
which is an extraordinary text that
centers the criminalization of black
girls in schools
um you can also pick up georgetown
center for poverty and law
has an excellent study and policy brief
on girl hood um
erased which touches on adultification
bias and that is pretty recent
um you can also watch push out the film
it is viewed
and it is readily accessible on pbs
right there's so many different texts
that you can take i also would push you
to think about
a woman racing class by angela davis
right our prisons obsolete
and so as you're thinking micro right
and as you're thinking about
you and your own um feelings
perspectives biases it's also the time
to connect yourself with organizations
that are already doing the work
right justice for black girls girls for
gender equity national black women's
justice initiative right
black lives matter in louisville right
there are folks that are on the front
lines
every day so as you are reading as you
are learning as you are unpacking
you can also then connect to send in
solidarity with the folks who are on the
front lines
i'm glad you mentioned the front lines
because we have to talk about
the protests that have been happening
you guys see visuals right now
of protests and there are several others
planned
for this year what do you think
the role of protests are in this
particular movement
sorry i'm taken aback by that visual um
but
protest is critically important to this
movement right and because
we know historically the power of
protests we know historically the power
of putting one foot in front of the
other and taking up space
um every time they take one of our
bodies our
others that are able and capable and
still alive
must stand up and stand in solidarity um
with folks to demand justice being
protesting is not just about taking up
physical space
it's about figuratively taking up space
right it's about demanding
um that stakeholders see us and
recognize us know that it's a problem
it's about standing in solidarity with
folks who are experiencing the pain
of having to even declare that black
lives matter think about how exhausting
that is
to consistently have to argue your
humanity
um and so folks are tired of having to
declare that our lives matter that
should be inherent
that should be innate folks should know
that if you have lungs
your lungs matter and so the fact that
we have to consistently declare
over and over again that black lives
matter and that black woman and girls
matter
and that black trans people matter right
that is exhausting and so
protest is critically important because
even though we're tired we keep pushing
even though we're weary we put one foot
in front of the other and we are working
to create the america we
know that we've always deserved is that
why it's so important to you to educate
people on this to create the america
we know we want and deserve yeah
absolutely
i think about um as i grew up in
richmond virginia um
all the ways i struggled with
placelessness and
um just displacement right in a world
that refused to recognize my full
identity i was often asked to fragment
myself and it took
a long time for me to realize that you
can't fragment yourself to make a broken
system powerful
um and so it's super important that we
um educate folks because i realize that
it's not that folks actively want to
dehumanize but they don't even realize
the ways in which they've been
socialized to inherent privilege um and
then inherent bias and then
inherit prejudice right and so there's
so many things that
that were in that were in place before
my existence
our existence and we have to do the work
to unpack um and so education is
critically important so that we can
um work again to create the america we
know we've always deserved
i mean but even before that it seems
like a certain level of
self-awareness yeah to happen first
and being able to possibly see yourself
in that position well that's kind of
what i'm hearing here
but i want to ask you something
different now
sure you said before we talked that
we got to work to create the world that
we know we deserve
do you feel a sense of hope with this
movement a lot of people have said
different yeah different for you do you
feel a sense of hope
yeah yeah um i will always find hope
um because i know that the power of my
ancestors lives within me
um right that we have always been our
our own saviors and that i
am standing here my ancestors wildest
dream um
there has to be hope we cannot get
hopeless because there's
always going to be work to do but you
can always think about the work that has
been done
it's not happening quick enough right
but it is happening
and the fact that folks know that this
is a problem the fact that there is
civil unrest from me
offers hope um that lets me know that
i'm not alone in what i'm feeling
um that i share the sentiments of other
folks and not just folks that look like
me
um but folks who don't um and that we
are working together to demand justice
and dismantle
all the systems that got us here right
and so there has to be
a hopefulness right even if you just
read one page of our prisons obsolete
and feel different
even if you just feel one page of new
jim crow even if you just read one page
of sabrina fulton's memoir right if you
just read one page
of tamika uh palmer brianna taylor's
mother's instagram page and
the ways that she um incites hope and
hopefulness
and folks as she's mourning the loss of
her child
you you have to find joy in knowing that
we
hold power right and that we can change
the world it doesn't feel like it all
the time
but we can and our ancestors do not want
us to grow weary and well
doing right we have to just again keep
putting one foot in front of the other
we have to lean on each other and know
that even when you feel
weak um there's someone else that is
strong enough to lead so that you can
follow and support
okay okay and what i understand is that
this is a lot of what your organization
talks about
as well as your freedom fighters fund
can you tell us a little bit about that
sure
um and so that fund was actually created
in honor of olympian salute
a 19 year old activist whose death lies
at the intersection of racial injustice
and gender-based violence
toyan was on the front lines and no one
showed up for her
um she was homeless and then sexually
assaulted in a place where she was
seeking refuge and then ultimately
killed
um and what we know again about
marginalization and oppression is that
there is never just one victim
and so in order for us to create the
america we know we deserve we have to
put in
on restorative practices and procedures
that address the core
issue right thinking about angela davis
radical means grasping things at the
root
so in that capacity we have a 100 000
distribution
that gives uh microgrants to black girl
activists on the front lines and so
black girls 25 and under are able to
apply and receive immediate funds
so that as they are on the front lines
fighting for um
america that we are standing up and
standing behind them
okay any last words um to the people
most impacted
by this news by these situations
specifically black women yeah
woman i'm a black woman do you have any
specific
closing thoughts to women at this time
i think what's most important at this
time is to remind us that we are sacred
that we are worthy um and
that all other folks stop asking black
women to prove that we are worthy
because we know that we are um and that
we deserve to be tired we deserve to be
angry we deserve to be upset
i mean do not pathologize our anger do
not pathologize our unrest
um and name our frustration what it is a
response to injustice
and a result in a response to the
systemic negligence of black women and
girls
um and so to all my black women to all
my black girls please
know that we are avidly fighting for
your full protection
um that we aspire a world that does not
just celebrate
um your death but is really really
focused on your life
um that we are looking for um an america
that honors the fullness of black
girlhood and is more concerned about our
experience in our aesthetic
a world that is not taking the
microphones away figuratively and
literally from black women and girls
but our standing um behind us too often
the narratives
is that we need to invite black women
and girls to the table
um but i declare um and i hope that
black women and girls
will believe that we are worthy of full
ownership of the table and we should
invite who we want to have a seat on our
own terms
okay all right thank you so much
um i really enjoyed our conversation and
i think that's a great place to leave it
um everyone uh please do check out
more information on justice for black
girls at
the social media handles that you've
seen throughout this broadcast i'm
ranita young with quick take
and have a great evening everyone all
right thank you so much